especially this day and age you just got
to be outlandish crazy that's why six
nine had such a you know people want to
be entertaining still to this day when
someone talks about six nine they'll be
like yeah [ __ ] uh they might hate
them they might love them but they're
always going to say like I miss them on
my timeline he was entertaining well I
see this about six nine well in general
what you just said the Outlander [ __ ]
only lasts so long oh of course it's no
longevity in that
but at least six nine
who was pretty much mastered the
internet at the time right at least he
had some good records he did he had some
records that didn't suck yeah yeah I
mean yeah gummo was a joint in the club
yeah bangers he even the Nikki record
was fire like that uh what was that [ __ ]
called Kiki Fifi Fifi Kiki whatever the
[ __ ] y'all know he'd be having these
[ __ ] weird-ass songs
but at least he had some records to kind
of back it up yeah but because it
wouldn't have worked if he didn't he's I
mean it would have worked momentarily
super a lot more gimmicky though yeah
you know it would have worked in the
sense of like little pump worked you
know and I guess they probably had
similar careers
and by the way for the second time in uh
uh [ __ ] little pump he put my number up
on his [ __ ] story [ __ ] him damn
because I had was it because the J Cole
thing yes you saw that right yeah oh by
the way I love J Coleman no no so me and
pump we're cool like I've always
defended him throughout the years yeah
we're a [ __ ] solid question to ask I
figured this kid might have been humbled
from the last few years let's have like
a grow up in conversation in which he
can actually kind of seem like a dude
and not like a [ __ ] clout robot you
know oh that was wrong
hey man some but sometimes I on that
kind of subject like some people don't
want to kind of admit kind of like where
they're at you know like that's the
thing is like you don't really
participate in a lot of that and you're
you have a a track record of like
like dude you've made more money off of
rap music than 90 of your peers and it's
not even close [ __ ] these [ __ ]
aren't getting royalty checked it don't
seem like it though no but they're not
getting royalty checks nobody's getting
royalty checks they're [ __ ] getting
their advance and then they're parlaying
that into show money or whatever the
[ __ ] but
[ __ ] ain't getting royalty
checks right like Meek Mill I think he
just said his whole career on Atlantic I
think he said yeah I've seen that it was
like a wildly low amount of money for as
many recipes like a million dollars or
something something crazy he asked how
much uh going bad made they're like 25
million he's like how much did I make
off that song no one told him anything
I'm like man so that's the problem
though like that's that those are the
that's label issues right there stay
away but this is the thing right like
it's a gamble because you could also be
the guy who's independent who well you
could be the guy who really ain't
who you're you might be a flash in the
pan and someone offers you two million
dollar deal yeah you better take that
exactly and that's how people think
sometimes Lil pump did that he got a bag
and good for him you got to bet on
yourself and when you're an artist and
if it happens quick then I get it but if
you're if you're building up and
building up and building up and you see
it's working for you and you have a shot
in this [ __ ] bet on yourself man gamble
on yourself and and [ __ ] don't take
that quick money that
you know instant gratification Build It
Up keep going it might take five years
but where are you gonna be yeah you guys
like rest these days who like kind of
like pimp the label for two albums and
then got the [ __ ] out and still owns his
Masters and now he's you know like he
just drops a song every week or every
two weeks it's like you just do what you
want you feed your fans yeah and I said
it that's another thing but it's also
aside from the label thing it's not
following the trends you know because I
don't think I don't think he followed
like super trendy like what was going on
in the music when like when pump was hot
like you know there was a lot of people
trying to do that you know coloring
their dreads doing all that pump is like
he's like the uh he's like the clout era
like mascot for sure but everybody
followed his whole [ __ ] those every
three years or every four years we we
give it like six nine Loki followed a
lot of like the pump [ __ ] even like oh
yeah I mean I mean just [ __ ] shocked
you know what I'm saying shock yeah
value there was the uh [ __ ] I'm not even
gonna say the dude's name because I was
dming with them
Chief Kee set the tone for a lot of [ __ ]
too there's there's a bunch of people
the Clone Guy what's his [ __ ] name I
was just dming with him because he's mad
that I forgot his [ __ ] name clone
kid boo kid boo yeah shout out to kid
boo I'm gonna have him on the podcast
we're gonna have a really honest
conversation about his whole [ __ ]
thing but
that was like yeah an egregious
era of of music oh it was all it was I I
think they call it the SoundCloud Era
SoundCloud I want to say Supreme not
everything Supreme Patty got a record
deal I think he did no
Supreme fatty uh Supreme patting the
lemon juice in his eyes guys put out a
record that was produced by Scott Storch
wow shout out Scott that's my guy get
the bag yeah but I'm pretty sure
somebody gave him a deal I don't want to
speculate on which company it was yeah
but let's just say
it's a number the company's named after
a number I'm pretty sure they gave him a
bag I might be wrong but the fact that
and supreme Patty's a nice kid but the
fact those kind of people are getting
record deals in the cloud era let me let
me let me say this man the industry
these labels it's it's like at first it
was like embarrassing but they tried to
hide it now they just don't have any
Pride like they're like [ __ ] it we're
already embarrassed they just did the
[ __ ] the fake crypto rapper yeah
they're like we're already [ __ ]
losing we're just gonna [ __ ] go all
out you know how when someone just gets
super desperate to [ __ ] just start
doing [ __ ] and they're [ __ ] you're
just like dude you have no [ __ ] shame
I feel like right now that's where we're
at with [ __ ] labels they're just like
oh he has a [ __ ] hot Tick Tock five
seconds snippet like we need them we
need them it's just